no but the lomashenko fight what'd you
think um i mean he's just an elite
two things one i thought um boxing's too
long
interesting yeah mma is is a better
sport for the casual fan
it's 25 minutes it is it is short it's
five rounds right so you need to be
impactful in each of those rounds
it's the tick tock of fight sports yes
yeah well said it's the length of a
sitcom
yeah that's it yeah yeah out of here
right and what's brilliant about it is
you need to demonstrate your ability in
front of the judges
every round yeah right you can't give
away
five rounds i mean i remember watching
like it was it maybe it was like floyd
versus oscar and i think oscar won like
the first five rounds and then floyd won
like the last seven or something yeah
but
you could do that as a boxer yeah you
could just take your time
there is no take your time in mma the
fact that it's only five rounds really
pushes you to be impactful yeah
you know uh and furthermore when you
want to talk about like celebrity boxing
like
i don't think jake paul or logan or them
should ever fight over eight rounds
yeah yeah keep it interesting yeah keep
it interesting exciting keep it short
around
shorter time go for the [ __ ] glory
right
jake swings he'd be taking swing you
can't do that for nine ten rounds
get it 11 12 rounds no chance so what
was interesting about the loma fight it
was boring in the first few rounds
and he's incredibly skilled and but once
he started to be
a little bit more impactful land some
big punches i mean he was a magician
he's an absolute wizard out there right
and he fought the right guy he fought
the guy that
beat my local no sorry that my
look-alike tia female lopez
apparently we look exactly the same so
shout-outs to fimo uh you're doing great
things with our face
we we he he fought him and went to a
decision
so lomo is like lomo's like i want to
fight that
guy and then knock him out right to
prove
that we should have another fight okay
because he wants that rematch right
against you female okay
so i think he earned it in my mind and
i'd love to see that fight again and
hopefully he can build some hype around
it but the sport needs to change a
little bit
shorter less time less you know
lomachenko lost to lopez the first time
yeah yeah
okay does i remember you i didn't know
but i remember you saying he's
maybe the best pound for pound in the
world yeah he wasn't floyd he was he was
best pound for a pound in the world he's
unbelievable he's not javonte davis oh
my god this guy can hit bro
yeah it seems exciting i remember i saw
a clip not remember i saw a clip of
floyd saying unofficially they're saying
you're losing right now
i kind of like that floyd said that yeah
and he felt almost guilty saying he's
like yo
i'm never gonna lie to you i'll be
honest with you and
most cards had him losing the first four
rounds yeah so
i like that he said that right he's
honest with his fighter if you lie to
your fighter he's not going to put out
the same effort
if you tell your fighter he's busting
the other guy's ass why would he change
anything
you have four rounds to nothing so you
can't criticize floyd for that also
that's floyd's fighter like floyd makes
money off him yeah
so you got to keep it a buck with the
guy you want to continue to win
and what'd he do got that [ __ ]
out of here yeah
um i don't know what did you guys think
of the loma fight we were all watching
it together i was impressed i had never
really seen him fight before
yeah so this is the first one where i
was like oh yeah like everything as far
as like footwork
speed like intensity like he just like
chopped him down the whole time yeah
pretty amazing to watch right amazing to
watch he follows through with every
punch like i like that it's not
there's no wasted punches yeah and i
like that about a fighter where it's
like
every punch is it's purposeful it's
perfect did it did you guys notice that
like
he would set up angles where he could
hit him
and then not be hit back it's like
really clever like what do you mean so
like what he would do sometimes is
he would he would strike he'd like he'd
very rare punch that you start with but
he would do a straight left he's a
southpaw so he'd do a straight left
usually you
start with a jab he'll be a straight
left and then he'd lean
to the side when he threw it and then
kind of sidestep around the guy
and then now he's out of both of his
hands to be countered right and then you
start throwing hooks
adam while he was right next to him and
it was really interesting because he was
so much shorter than the guy he had to
close distance
but he can't stand there and exchange
with him because the other guy
could potentially win those exchanges if
he's at a further distance right
so it was just super high fight iq man i
mean
he's amazing to watch he's so much fun
to watch especially with the footwork
i need to see a replay because whenever
people talk about the sweet science i
don't normally get it
yeah that seems like honestly oh yeah
you could see it with him he is but
again
we watched fighters that we didn't even
know who the [ __ ] they were earlier that
night on an mma card yeah more
interesting
really it's undeniably more interesting
breaks my heart to say as a boxing fan
but it is more interesting
yeah and respecting nakatani the guy he
was fighting yeah that guy like
you got a chin bro his head was getting
snapped back over the ropes i saw that
yeah the difference in punches landed
with some crazy [ __ ] like 101 to 24 or
something
oh yeah i mean it was but the way that
the punishment i mean he looked like a
[ __ ] pez dispenser dude
boom every every single punch
you